what i want to do in this video is
introduce you to what i think is one of
the
neatest ideas in computer science and
that is recursion so the way that we've
defined this factorial function in the
last few videos is actually an iterative
definition we are iterating through
different values for this variable i and
then we're essentially taking those
values adding one then multiplying those
times our original product and when we
keep iterating through all of that our
eventual product has all of the values
from one through the number multiplied
by each other and they're all sitting in
this variable product what i'm going to
do here is rewrite this program what's
cool about
functions i'm going to rewrite this
function what's cool about functions are
this function we just say look it
returns a factorial of a number we don't
care how this is actually written and so
anything that's using this function
called no matter how i implement it as
long as i implement it correctly it
shouldn't worry about it so as long as i
implement this the insides the guts of
this function right even if i can do it
in a very different way it shouldn't
affect the behavior of any of the
functions that call it so let's let's go
ahead and try to define this function
recursively and i think it's you're
going to find this slightly fascinating
so i'm going to do it a little bit
different we're going to get put some
conditionals in here as well
so i'm going to say
so it's almost in some ways recursion is
really deep and complicated on some
levels it's way simpler than anything
else so let me just put all this stuff
stuff down there
so i'm going to say look if the number
you always want to think about a base
case what's the situation where
if kind of the the the nugget or the
smallest values we can put into for
number that'll give us a decent response
so we'll say look
if
if
number if number is let's say if it's
less than or
equal to 1
so if it's less than or equal to 1 let's
just return well then it's factorial
let's just return one especially if we
want to have it have the same behavior
as the old function the old function
regardless of whether we put a 1 there a
0 there actually even if we put a
negative 1 or negative 2 there it always
gave us the factorial being equal to 1.
so that's exactly what we're doing over
here we're returning one if the number
is less than one and this also defines
our base case i'll i can even label it
here so let me label this is our this is
our base case
and you'll see what i mean for a second
by a base case and this is what i'm
about to do now this is the really
exciting part about recursion if the
number if the number is not less than or
equal to one so i could write l if
so this or maybe i'll just write else
actually so if the number is not less
than or equal to 1 i'm going to return
something different and what i'm going
to return is
that number
that number times
the factorial
times the factorial of one less than
that number
now the reason why this is fascinating
and cool and all the rest is i just
define something using that something so
i just defined a function called
factorial and i define it using the
definition of the function factorial it
is referring to itself this is what
recursive functions do but if you think
about it and i'll diagram it out in more
detail in the next video so hopefully it
makes a little bit more sense it should
kind of work because if you put a if you
put a 1 or a 0 in for a number it'll
just return 1. what happens if i if
number is 2 well if number is 2 it'll
say look number is not less than or 1 so
i'll go over here so it says it'll
return
2 times
factorial of 2 minus 1 or factorial of
1. and then it'll call factorial again
and factorial of 1 is just 1. so it'll
return 2 times 1. so that will work out
for 2.
try it for 3.
if you do factorial of 3 it'll go down
to this clause over here because 3 is
not less than or equal to 1 it'll return
3 times the factorial of
3 minus 1 which is 2 the factorial of 2.
well we know it already returns the
right answer for the factorial of 2 so
it'll return 3 times 2 which is 6 which
is a factorial of 3. so hopefully you're
getting the gist of it factorial of 4 is
going to work for the exact same reason
it's going to boil down to 4 times a
factorial of 3. we know that it works
for the factorial of three and just to
prove to you that i'm not doing some
type of crazy voodoo and that this will
actually work let's try to run the
program
let's try to run the program right here
so let's turn this is some stuff that i
was doing beforehand that let me just
get rid of that
so let's just run the program so all
i've done is i've redefined the
factorial function but i've redefined it
recursively so recursively well i won't
have to change the comment so let me
save it and let's let's run let's
interpret this program let's execute it
and see if it does what we need it to do
all right so we and so they're prompting
us for something let's take the
factorial of five
120 and so once again our factorial
program no matter what we put in there
it gives us the right answer but what's
really cool is it's now doing it
recursively when i do factorial of 6
saying okay factorial of 6. is 6 less
than or equal to 1 well no it's not so
it goes to this else clause right over
here so then it says return 6 times the
factorial of 5 then it says okay let me
remember 6 times a factorial of 5 let's
figure out what factorial of 5 is well
factorial 5 is going to be 5 times a
factorial of 4. and so and then that
factorial of 4 is 4 times a factorial 3
all the way down to the factorial of 1
which is 1. and so it'll actually return
6 times 5 times 4 times 3 times 2 times
1.